das sechzehnte züricher filmfestival ist
das erste festival während der korona
pandemie das trotzdem stattfindet und
zwar mit gesten und ohne die vielen
einschränkungen eine eigene konzept gibt
es natürlich trotzdem und in zürich
werden dann dabei sein johnny depp
moritz bleibtreu und til schweiger neben
vielen anderen aber schon vor dem
festival hat iris berben heute eine
auszeichnung bekommen und zwar das
goldene auge für ihr lebenswerk und sie
nutzte die bühne dieses awards dafür um
einmal klartext zu sprechen
ich würde nicht mal sagen ich kann mir
gar nicht anmaßen zu sagen zu wenig weil
ich weiß wie die politik gerade
gefordert wird und zwar aus jeder
branche aber es ist so
dies ist meine branche alle stelle ich
natürlich die forderungen auch für mich
ist das eine der ersten forderung es ist
eine wirtschaftliche förderung aber es
ist auch eine kulturelle forderung die
wir haben und ob eine politik ich will
das gar nicht sagen zu wenig macht 7
muss sich ordnen ich weiß was da alles
auf sie einströmen
aber wir müssen ganz laut dabei bleiben
und sagen kultur ist ebenso wichtig wie
jeder andere förderung die die ihr
vergebt und über die er nachdenkt und
über die über die wege die wir finden
müssen dass wir das wir ein
gesellschaftliches leben einfach wieder
zum zum erwachen bringen und da ist eine
politik gefordert da es ist die branche
gefordert wege finden möglichkeiten
finden dass wir unter diesen umständen
die wir haben
die kultur weiterhin und die filme
weiterhin zeigen können dass menschen
die lust glaube ich haben die menschen
ins kino zu gehen daran liegt es ja
nicht den die müssen wir ihnen gar nicht
machen aber wir müssen ihnen die
möglichkeiten bieten sich filme
anzuschauen ohne dass sie das gefühl
haben
verunsichert zu sein wir müssen auch in
der politik darauf achten dass keine
angst verbreitet wird wir dürfen nicht
in dieser angst erstarren
ich glaube das wichtigste ist menschen
immer wieder klar zu machen dass die
forschung bedeutet dass dinge sich auch
verändern auch verändern können
verändern werden und dass wir menschen
darauf immer wieder auch einstimmen das
die veränderung ein ganz normaler
prozess ist und nicht bedeutet dass man
den jetzt sofort wieder alles andere in
die tonne treten kann sondern wir müssen
mit diesen diesen vorsichtigen
veränderungen umgehen
und wir erfahren ja immer mehr auch über
dieses virus und das sollten wir
umsetzen in die praxis das sollten wir
umsetzen zu sagen wo können wir
eigentlich großzügiger schon wieder sein
wie können wir es handhaben und wie
können wir den größtmöglichen schutz
bieten und damit die leute das trotzdem
das schöne gefühl der kultur haben
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren